- You're sitting in
your office and you know
that for the next day
you still need to create
an extensive slide presentation
of 10, 20, 30 pages.
So what do you do?
You just work all night to do that?
Do you want to think about the layout
of every single slide in an extensive way?
No, this is surely not what
I would recommend you to do.
What you need
are some very good design
and layout principles
that you can rely on to just produce.
Just produce the deck, we
don't need to think too much
about how every individual
slide needs to look like.
This is exactly what I wanna
talk about to you today.
My name is Heinrich, I'm a
former McKinsey Consultant
and on my channel I want to help you
to create slide presentations
in the same style
the leading consulting firms
like Boston Consulting Group or Bain do.
And today we're going to
talk about slide layouts
and throughout the
video we're going to see
lots of example slides and I
will offer all of those to you
as a download as an open PowerPoint file
so you can use them for
yourself as a template.
There's a download link to
them in the video description
feel free to check them out.
And before we jump in, I wanna
say thank you to Think Cell
for sponsoring this video.
Think Cell is a tool that I
literally used almost every day
to improve my PowerPoint slides.
You will hear more about them later today.
The key principle I
want to talk about today
is that every slide is a table.
When creating slides,
you should always think
about organizing information
on the page in a table format.
So what I do not mean by that
is that you should indeed
just insert a table in PowerPoint
as maybe it looks like here on the slide.
But instead you should
always consider your page
being a collection of rows and columns,
and always organize your
information in this framework.
So every slide is a table, but
what exactly does this mean?
So in order to make this
a little bit more tangible
I will structure this video
along three main types
of slides.
First qualitative slides,
second quantitative slides
and third integrated slides.
We want to integrate both qualitative
and quantitative information.
So let's directly jump into the section
on qualitative slides.
And I'm gonna always start
by first showing you a
general slide blueprint,
and then some actual examples
so you can bring this format to life.
You'll see a basic layout for
a qualitative slide like that.
I hope you directly
recognize the table format.
In the columns you have the
different types of information
that you want to talk about.
And this is one key thought
that whenever you have
different types of information,
you will include that
in different columns.
This is an error that
many people are doing.
They're just having a page
just with a list of bullet points.
And then maybe the first bullet point
is about a general principle.
The second bullet point
is about an example.
The third bullet point
is about a suggestion
that you are making, you
are mixing different types
of logical information,
different logical types of data.
You should always then separate
this in different columns.
Then in the rows, you will
typically present different types
of information that you apply
the things that you talk about
in the headers to.
The general idea is to avoid
just a long list of bullets
to avoid these so-called cloth lines.
If you have no idea what a cloth line is
and why you should avoid it.
I created a video about that in the past.
I will link it somewhere above
here for you to reference.
It's really a key concept.
Check it out if you haven't seen it yet.
So for the theory,
let's look at a couple
of practical examples.
So here you have a version
of this very slides,
we have first the column for the measures.
So the different measures
that you're proposing
and then on the right
column for the rationale.
So why do you think
this measure is needed?
And you have nicely organized
all these measures in rows.
Of course, this is a very
wordy, a very text heavy slide.
So likely not something for your main deck
but maybe something for appendix.
The think it nicely
illustrates the principle
with this table format, you
can very nicely aggregate
and show this data.
Next there may be a little
bit more complicated version
of such a page of a first column
with the name of the
recommendation that you have,
a second column with the details.
What exactly is it that
you're recommending.
A third column with the average impact
that maybe you are estimating
to include it as a number
and then an additional
column for the roadmap,
for the timing of it all.
Again, notice how different
types of information
are stretched out to different columns.
And then the logical elements
that you want to talk about
are organized in the row.
This is a very typical
standard slide format
that you will be able to
create in a quite quick
and straightforward way.
And again, all these slides
that I will show you here in this video
offered to you as a download
in an open PowerPoint format,
check out the link in
the video description
if this is of interest to you.
Next, just an additional layout idea
to illustrate that you don't always
need to follow this strict column format
with the column headers.
Of course, for the columns, you
can also use other elements.
For instance, here on this example,
a timeline or maybe also process chart
with different process bars
that you could use for the columns.
So you could of course play with it,
include some creativity in it.
So the slides surely do not need to look
all the same and you
can mix it up as needed.
Next let's look at quantitative charts.
So charts that have some
data visualization on it,
some charts, some diagrams on it.
Of course this is a very common chart
and probably the majority
of all the charts
that you will create, at least
in professional services.
So let's look what you can
do with the layouts in here.
But before we do that,
let me introduce you
to a tool that I learned
to love during my career
in consulting.
It is a tool that is used
by almost all the big consulting firms.
It is the defacto standard
to create professional slides
in the style of leading consulting firms
like McKinsey, BCG and Bain.
And this tool is called Think Cell.
It is a PowerPoint plug
and that up until this day,
in my current role in a startup company
I use almost every single day.
It is a tool that nicely
integrates a PowerPoint.
And even if you feel like
that you do not need it
at the moment, just the
fact alone that it is used
by almost all of the big consulting firms
should be reason enough for you
to pick up the basics of it,
because this is a tool that
you will likely be expected
to use on a very regular basis
in many of the big consulting firms.
So if consulting is a
career that interests you,
better pick up the basics on things
that this will for sure be
very well invested time.
Think Cell doesn't only
help to create effective
and beautifully looking charts
but also has lots of functionalities
to help to create a good and
sound layout on your pages
following the style that
I will teach to you here
in this video.
And the best thing is
that I actually negotiated
a special offer with Think Cell
for the Firm Learning community.
If you sign up to Think Cell
via the link in the video description,
you get, first of all a 60 day free trial,
this is double the usual
size, no credit cards required
or any other hidden costs.
And then if you do decide
to continue using Think Cell
after the trial, you will
be offered single licenses.
This is usually not possible
in the Think Cell offering
but with this link here for
the Firm Learning community
you can purchase a
license just for yourself.
So if this does sound interesting to you
try out Think Cell via the
link in the video description.
I can personally very
much recommend the tool.
Let's now jump into quantitative slides.
What you see here on this
page is arguably the mother
of all quantitative slide layouts.
And again, I hope that
you directly recognize
the table format.
So on the first column, we have a column
on the methodology that you applied here
for your data analysis.
And the second column, we have the chart
with the data visualization
that you want to highlight.
And then in the third
column we have a column
on the implications of this page.
What is the so what of this page.
Frankly, easily 50% of
all of the pages I created
in consulting followed some version
of this very basic layout.
And in many cases you don't
even need the first column
on the methodology.
You have more space than for the chart,
for the data visualization configured out
and then focus on the right
with a couple of bullets.
What implications you need are,
what the reader, recipient
of your presentation
is actually supposed to
take away from this chart.
But let's look at a couple of examples.
This will be a very basic layout
following exactly this methodology.
So on the left, you have the diagram
showcasing in the bubble
chart format the market size,
the growth, the profitability, the margin
of certain regions.
And then on the right,
you have a simple column
highlighting a couple of
points, a couple of key insights
that you want to
communicate to the reader.
Here again, this layout is very basic,
but I hope you agree if you
produce a slide like that,
you will never get the feedback
that this is not looking professional.
This is a very solid page,
always just following
this very basic layout
that we just discussed.
Next example, here is
simple waterfall chart.
Because the truth is that
sometimes you don't even need
the additional column on the right.
Maybe the chart out of itself
is already self explanatory
or maybe you just want to
highlight a couple of points
within the chart.
Then you can do it with
this little element
that you see right here.
This is something that is
sometimes called a call out.
So just the text box
with two line elements
to showcase that also just
the variation of this layout
that we just discussed.
Let's now move to the third type of slide.
And these are integrated slides
and these are arguably
the most interesting ones
because the truth is that this
is a style of creating slides
that I think is very very
common in professional services
in consulting, if you work for a firm
like McKinsey, BCG, Bain,
but it's not that often
seen outside of consulting.
And this is a style where you're trying
to integrate the diagram, the chart
even more into your table with the text.
So earlier we've seen
this very simple example
where maybe on the left,
you have a chart or diagram
and then on the right list
of bullets with implications.
And again, this is surely, okay
you can do that, but now the
problem maybe, the downside
is that now there's a certain disconnect
between your bullets and the chart.
People now need to read the bullets
and maybe they didn't find
something interesting.
Now they need to look at the chart
and now they need to try to make the link.
And especially if the chart's
maybe a little bit more complex
this is often not so easy.
And it for sure takes
additional cognitive energy
of the person looking
at this to make sense
out of all the information
that are presented here.
And so the idea of these integrated charts
and let me maybe directly
jump to an example
is to really integrate the chart
together with additional
bullets with other information
into the table structure.
Again, here you see a chart
where on the left you have a title
and then you have a simple bar chart
then a column with details
and then additional column
with strategic assessment.
And also notice how this additional column
out there on the right
is in the end of the day,
nothing else than an additional column
that was inserted there.
So always think about
whether it makes sense,
whether there's an opportunity
to include such a diagram
into your table structure.
And don't just have two
very separated columns
where then on the left, you have a diagram
on the right you have a list of bullets.
Of course, this doesn't always make sense,
but often there is a good opportunity
to do something like this.
And then this really helps the reader
to just process the information
in a more direct way.
Let's look here at an additional
example here on the left.
In the first column, you
have this waterfall chart
then second column, this
additional number dimension
with the circles, and then on the right,
you have this column of implications.
So again, this is not too far away
from this qualitative blueprint
we talked about earlier,
but notice how here there's this shade
on a very specific part of the diagram
where again, you really try
to integrate information
provided to the right,
with this very specific
element of the chart.
Again, this just an additional little tool
that you can use to
integrate information more
to create these nicely integrated slides
that we are talking about here.
But in the end of the
day, this is nothing else
than a table format again.
So hope this makes sense
and now you understood what exactly I mean
by treating every single
slide like a table.
As I told you earlier, if
you're interested in downloading
any of these slides, there's
a download link to them
in the video description
to an open PowerPoint file.
I once again wanna extend a big thank you
to Think Cell for sponsoring this video.
There's a link to Think Cell
in the video description as well.
And via this link you will have access
to a 60 day extended free trial
and also the opportunity
to purchase single licenses
which is usually not
possible with Think Cell.
If this video provided
any value to you at all
please destroy the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to the channel
and turn on notifications to
stay up to date on my content.
Big, big, thanks to the
members of Firm Learning,
your support is very much appreciated.
As you know, I'm Heinrich,
the creator of this channel.
I release weekly videos,
so very much looking
forward to next Saturday.
So if you want to continue developing
your slide writing skills,
I will insert here an additional video
on slide writing next to me.
So check that out, looking
forward to see you again soon,
all the best to you.